[Music]
[Music]
ain't no competition in the ring or
cipher cause i'm spitting financial
swing of fire talking pickled peppers
make them pay the piper cause i might go
look like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food reduction you'll
be talking like you want a new
concussion to do the custom attitude
adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i will serve having
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
capping you a phony homie now you owe me
action have him sinking tony tony tony
braxton and they all wanna talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
instant mama got hands so i'm ready for
the tension i'm gonna leave him ready
you can dance
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
[Music]
[Music]
a fool reduction you'll be talking like
you want a new concussion to do the
custom attitude adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i would serve having
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
capping you a phony homie now you owe me
action have him sinking tony tony tony
braxton and they all want to talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
instant mama got handsome and bread for
the pension i'm gonna leave him red you
can dance
[Music]
definitely
welcome to another oh hold on
gotta switch that up boy
this is this is
this is where you be
messing up brother
hold on
what's going on everybody
let me fix that up real quick
there we go
there we go
i
there we go
what's going on everybody
it won't be combat talk if it ain't the
professional fan messing up in some form
or fashion
what's going on people
thank you thank you thank you oh oh
one of the dragons
my man who else is in here oh oh
awful grim bones my dude he was the
first one in there we got 17 watching
teo fema lopez tonight baby
oh man yo
my my my thoughts on this kid
be honest with you um
i was a little bit afraid
of um
what what would happen you understand
like
what what what
what what's gonna happen to him
because
fighting loma
coming down from a super high
then
getting beat by cambosis in a way that
he got beat by cambosis remember he was
braggadocious going all the way into
that right so he was talking mad crap
going into it
what's going on back
he was talking mad crap going into it
and um
cambodia's just never backed down from
him
so
we all thought just cam bosses just had
this big mouth he was just a big mouth
dude because nobody really knew who came
best was if um
if you want to sit there and say you
knew who cam bosses was you
probably telling tall tales
oh
before we get started
what you sipping on what you what you
sipping on
tequila sunrise
beautiful
tequila sunrise nice uh
and this one i put a dash of lemon
i had um
i have whatchamacallit there too i had
some um some lime so i put a spritzer
lime and a dash of lemon
put the orange juice and i put the
orange juice on layers then i put the
tequila in there the rest masado
put that in there
then
the cranberry came at the top like boom
bash paws
yo
definitely dope great flavor
something to get you know chill and
mingle with this is what's up so
like i said first thousand people in
it's one in your refrigerator
he said lemon goes with everything
that's the show
and yeah you you right now on medication
sir so
uh yeah you just drinking that ginger
ale
oh hard to find what's good
salami my brother
oh mr salam my bad brother that's a
salami
and i just had one sip crazy
yo so
to female right
i just i don't know i don't know what to
expect from this kid because remember he
was he was here
he was the dude that went and beat loma
so
we thinking all right he beat loma
he's gonna fight devin haney
shakur is gonna come up and fight him
he's gonna fight tank
and he he did a bunch of bizarre things
right
he went and um
went to trilla
because he didn't want to fight those
dudes
and top rank wanted him to fight those
dudes
but he wanted to fight cambosis but then
i i don't know it was just a series of
weird events with loma and then
it was just like he he was too high on
his horse or something i
i don't know man
so
excuse me
when he lost to loma i mean uh lost to
um
to to to cambosis
i was just like wow like
it it threw everything off
so so
tio tio has to show me something tonight
he has to show me
uh that his confidence is there
because that that was confidence shaking
like to
remember cambodia came out in the first
round and dropped them and having them
off his deem the whole fight to be
honest with you for me
um
and i really think that uh
i think i think
you know lopez this is this
this is a a make or break type of fight
to see where he's at he looked great in
shape he went up in weight i i believe
that he was struggling with weight
before and i believe weight was an issue
but i also feel that
excuse me separating himself
away from secor stevenson getting away
from devin haney
getting out of the division with
cambosis
uh
actually separating himself from tank
because at 140 and he came in a light
tonight you know he came in at 138
so that means that he was still able to
make 135
right uh so
what's what's the mindset in in
in his is his behavior
is his i don't know it's just
does he feel a safe at 140
did he feel stronger
at 140 that he could take shots better
at 140 i mean because remember it's five
pounds to us but it's it's a lot more
that goes into that you know behind the
scenes and stuff but um
i don't know man this is this is a
strange one
and um i normally
don't really like top rank fights you
know um
top ranked fights is usually you know
setup fights
you know and
but you know top rank does put on some
good shows here and there
like the the lomachenko uh tio fimo
and that was that was a really good one
so
i really think this um
this isn't as bad the card isn't as bad
as the zones card last week i wasn't
going to subject y'all to last week card
last week's card to me
was hot trash
all right so
we have 19 people watching
thank you for tuning in to the
professional fan
king david
iron lords podcast yo hit the cash app
cash at work fund me bank is real that's
not like a joke i know you'll see five
five five five five and y'all like uh
that funny bank ain't real that's real
um
that's if you wanna directly you know
donate or whatever that's what's up and
um
or super chat or just just mix it up
with everybody inside you know the chat
share it out to a friend we're going to
get over to this fight soon as this
fight happened we we
uh two fights away yeah actually one
fight away you have the undercard the
co-main event and then you have the
actual main event
i
i want theo
to be in good spirits because i always
thought he was one of those pillars in
the division to actually give back let
me see what's going on
necromancer what's going on what's going
on
ah live supremacy what's going on
that's what's up
what's up
egon what's going on oh yeah i'm gonna
be crazy messy tomorrow anybody tuning
in tomorrow you already know i'm about
to be tuning in tomorrow with the uh
stop snitching no rats man we don't we
we we don't condone informants we don't
condone rat and we don't condone that in
any form or fashion so any dudes
representing or or you know
down with the rat squad you know with
the six nine face not doing that out
here
you can't you can't be in the game
snitching on dudes that's playing the
game just like you you set the rules
you know you you're boss so we're going
to get into that tomorrow though
but you know no ratting nah not in here
you know no but drinks in here
everything's off the books this year
let me see let me see
excuse me
that's the colbert
a gym six nine ryan that's crazy that's
what's going on
total dope what's up what's up that's
right that's right
yo um tio
i'm not gonna tio always look good
like uh as far as how he looked um
getting ready for this fight his his his
shape always looked good he looks like
he was way
working on
defense and
countering
he's he's a real good uh offensive
fighter
very underrated defensive fighter
um
tto teo has a space here
i wish he would uh um
honestly
took the loss to cambosis better
honestly i really wish he would have uh
because to me it that kind of tarnishes
things you know when you feel that when
when a boxer actually loses he's so
emotionally invested in in the fight i
mean
we all are right
but you have to learn how to win and
lose gracefully you know um that's why i
love anthony joshua
anthony joshua he he wins and he loses
with grace
and that's something that's something
very hard to teach a young fighter
you know as they're going up because
your competitive juices is so strong you
had such a place mentally and physically
that the
the conception of loss is not even in
your brain but when reality sets in
you have to hit that switch
and you can't become
the next adrian broner the next meme you
can't you can't beat that you can't beat
that dude
and sound like sour grapes you got to
say the better man one tonight keep it
very short and simple the better man won
tonight next time hopefully i do better
that's it
and
it's just you know i don't know
hopefully hopefully that's better but we
got good news
for those bud fans yes yes yes
seems like blood is coming around seems
like stuff is almost there follow spence
fans yes yes
you know dudes gonna get exactly what
they want in the ring hopefully they
talking about november
those those things sound really good
um anthony joshua versus usyk ii
uh oh
for the fans of tyson fury
i told you before
he was going to retire
you know and
he had nothing left to prove
he came back from drug addiction
and you know was uh is he still battling
those demons and stuff like that being
in that environment that environment
puts him around those demons that he's
battling
uh he came back
uh to have a three-fight trilogy
with the greatest knockout artist in
boxing history which is deontay wilder
i'm not saying the greatest boxer i'm
just saying the greatest knockout his
his ko ratio was crazy
and in heavyweight history um
excuse me that's why he has this uh
competitive thing with mike tyson
mike tyson really never acknowledges
uh deontay's wallace dante wilder's um
prowess
i guess you know i don't know i don't
know what's going on with those two but
he came back he did exactly what he set
out to do
become the the heavyweight champion
again because he left with the lineal
championship
and um
[Music]
oh
before i go any further with that this
teal female lopez this espn crap talking
about millennial champion
he's not the lenient champion he lost to
cambodia's cambodia's beat him
excuse me
and devin haney beat cambosis
devin haney is the champion
and uh mute that mic right there that
cough was crazy
taking my throat pause
so you know he's coming up with all
these excuses uh teo fimo and
that's not cool
so
you know tyson fury came back as the
lineal champion
and
he fought the hardest craziest fight
that he could fight
deontay wilder
you know and and he did a hell of a job
he showed
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm feeling i'm
feeling better i'm feeling a little bit
better
facebook user's in there what's going on
um
trust me yo first of all
everybody sending their uh uh uh good
wishes uh well wishes to
108 dragons lemon definitely you know
for the lake situation
um
and my boy graphic guard
please um you know he's getting he's
getting over his vid you know i'm i'm
getting over about with the vid
and and i got vaccinated
both of them so you know every so often
you you get a little chest congestion a
cough
uh
stuff like that um so
it
it feels like uh
more heavier handed flu
so
that's that's how i deal with it you
know deal with the the tea with the
lemon and all that other stuff and
and um
contrary to
popular belief
i only have one drink and that's for the
show you know so
that's it
now
but um
and hopefully this lasts the whole thing
um i try to stay
in in in good health and and try to keep
up with my the team everybody making
sure everybody else is good
but um
so
i don't know uh
you're looking at the two the two
fighters you're looking at teo femo you
know 16 1 and 12
uh pedro uh
33 1-1 in in in 22 knockouts
um
they they pick people
with good records and place them
against champions that are very capable
of former champions or fighters that are
very capable
so don't don't get fooled by the
how
big uh
campers record is campus record is what
it's supposed to be for feeding him
basically to teal to to to lopez um
sometimes that can go terribly wrong
you know everybody didn't know cambosis
too so you so you see
uh a lot of times that can go wrong and
you don't want to build your fighter off
of
a weak opposition because when they do
have to fight or do have to step up and
fight strong opposition
then they don't have the necessary
skills to do so they can't walk through
that fire you know
because they still isn't tested their
heart isn't tested their endurance is
and tested their mind
isn't tested they don't believe in
themselves to the point where you know
you can make it through you know
thinking about deontay wilder which he's
making a comeback as well
i don't think that that uh his opponent
is set yet
but um
[Music]
thinking about deontay wilder
he maybe didn't have all the skills in
the world but his level of belief and
his confidence within himself that said
that he's willing to die out there his
integrity his heart his stuff that's on
the line
uh that man is is what you want
inside each and every last one of your
fighters you know so
he's another one i didn't like
how he handled
his losses at the end
you know stay in the ring
better man one tonight
moving on
so you know hopefully hopefully
oh seattle oh my god ellis was good
when's the next punch-out game coming
out
when somebody when somebody makes it
oh thank you thank you isaac thank you
thank you thank you the try to i yo
got the guy
got the the the camera on deck got the
light sourcing got the microphone
popping got the side uh uh uh monitor
popping got the other monitor got the
monitor in the middle got the high power
pc you know everybody got a playstation
got a high power cbc oh no no is
everybody who got xbox got high power pc
right
um but yeah yeah man
this this
i i just want to see these dudes mix it
up
i want devin haney to get ahead and
fight cambodia's who's to say cambosis
is not the dark horse in all of this
like who's to say cambosis is not the
one
what if he upsets the apple cart and
and
that that magic um performance that uh
devin haney put on against cambosis in
the last fight where he won all the
belts and he's the undisputed champion
what what if cambosis
flips it
and he wins the next one
what the hell does that do
man um
that changes things
and then then you have ryan garcia
that's
you know he wants to be at
140 i think
i think quiet is kept
tio
is
targeting
ryan garcia
i think teo
knows ryan garcia's chin
isn't all that special
but let me tell you something let me let
me explain sometimes this is where the
hunter
becomes the hunted yo we got 30 people
in there we got 20 likes let's get that
up shout out push that out to people
this is where the hunter
becomes the hunted
and let me explain
ryan garcia
he's a big boy
nice wide back nice broad shoulders
broad chest
a v taper
he does a lot of things wrong like when
he bops out his head is on a swivel his
head is up but it's you know sticking up
in the sky he don't tuck his chin when
he slide back
and that was something that de la hoya
had to learn early on to tuck your chin
when you slide back and you move to the
left or you move to the right
when you get out of danger
and that that's something that can be
taught he could learn that
right if he if he wants to listen he
could learn that
and i i do believe
that um
his trainer is going to teach him
because he's he's only had his training
what
one or two fights
so okay
do you think hits harder
ryan garcia
or george cambosis junior
i'll wait
who do you think hits harder
ryan garcia
or george cambosis jr
i believe ryan garcia hits
harder than him
by a country mile
by a country mouth i believe that boy
hits like a mule kick
okay
he yo
he hit fortuna
with a short tucked in left hook
that is
muscle memory
from the shoulder ha
he yanked it so fast the only person i
saw throw a punch faster than that was
bruce lee and they couldn't catch it on
camera
the reason why i said the only person
that was faster that i seen with with
with the eye is bruce lee because they
couldn't catch the punch on camera
they actually caught
uh garcia's punch on camera that he hit
fortuna with
very sharp and you had to watch it in
super super slow-mo
technology is different than now than it
was then with bruce lee maybe we would
have been able to catch that punch but
i'm just saying this to say
he threw that
with so much talk
with so much muscle memory without
thinking he let it rip and remember i
told you he gotta get out of his brain
when he's fighting
if that man hits teo fema lopez
with
one of those shots
and
can't george cambos has dropped theo and
he put tio in some spots in that fight
ryan will probably snatch his head off
his shoulders
okay so
i'm a huge
fan of excellence
and pure
athletic ability
and i believe that boy got it i believe
i believe ryan garcia
has the ability to transcend the sport
the same way oscar de la hoya
transcended the sport
as being
a icon slash uh uh a boxer
you know that the celebrities like he
has the the
the ability to bridge the gap
he gets social media
he gets the whole
the same way jake
paul and his and his brother
uh get how to manipulate the people into
believing things
he knows how
all right so he can bring all because
remember ryan garcia has never fought
for a title and he doesn't have a title
but
the perception of this man is that he
has been a champion and is a champion
right
the perception of this man is you
believe that he is some form of champion
or have been in championship battles and
he's battle tested
that couldn't be further from the truth
absolutely not
so
his ability to manipulate the masses on
a scale of that
level
can bring the people to watch the fight
and when he does get into said fight if
he gets into a fight with teo
and tio isn't top
on his square the same way he was on his
score when he fought loma and loma
caught him with some good shots there
too
and loma is not the heaviest handed
person
um
[Music]
we might be watching the hunter
turn into the hunted
and oscar de la hoya knows that
in this whole equation
where does tank fit
because it seems like everybody is is
talking these dudes and moving in this
direction
and nobody wants to fight taylor it's
like they wait and tank out like
he got to slow up
like people really wanted pit bull
cruise to beat him they really wanted
him to beat him
and
the fact that he didn't they like damn
all right i guess you gotta fight man i
got a mandatory i'm not i'm
let him go ahead do his thing
so he has to fight all these other dudes
rolly
rolly rolly wasn't ready yet rolly had
to be at least three fights away from
tank
let me see kane
haney and shaquille stevenson will whoop
garcia
um
that is yet to be determined
uh
and and i'm gonna tell you ellis that is
yet to be determined because
devin haney sure enough has boxing
skills devin haney sure enough has heart
i believe demon haney will fight anybody
but you're saying let's say at 140 right
because devin haney is at 130.
so you're saying at 140 right
at 140 oh devin hayes is 135.
you're saying that 140 where ryan garcia
and his campaign and that
devin haney has to get there to fight
him
devin haney is not the bigger dude in
that fight he's damn sure not the
stronger puncher
so that means you're going to have to
outbox ryan garcia for 12 rounds
and
and
try not to get hit because we all know
his chin
ain't the best chin in the yard you know
he has that anthony joshua stuffing
there going on with the
with his beard piece
his beard pieces the question here
the only person there in that equation
is shaco stevenson
she called stevenson
you believe that he has the boxing skill
he has the power even though he slaps
with his punches
he's a little bit more um how can he say
it uh
um
stronger with his punches
than devin haney
even though i think he slaps with his
punches i think they have to teach him
how to you know just show it up to my
little jersey too my little jersey drew
shore it up you know um hang around uh
zab judah a little bit more get that pop
pop bring it back
um
i i don't know man
that ryan garcia versus devin haney
haney's a 50 50 to me
yeah he got a glass bed man
to me
and i love the kid
i lo i love the whole dynamic when it
comes to the whole devin haney team
how his father removed himself and
allowed his son to be and grow into the
man
yo
i i know we all don't have blueprints on
how to raise our kids right and we damn
sure don't know how to i have a
blueprint on how to raise millionaire
kids
all right so raising broke kids is hard
as hell could you imagine raising a
millionaire kid
a kid that you know
into a man and he still has that respect
for his pops
and his pops has his the respect for his
son
that he stepped back and he's like yo if
you don't need me in the business i'll
slide back you know i'm gonna let you do
your thing
yo
i love the dynamic
but their dynamic ain't gonna save his
chin
all right so i just had to say that that
i i i i love and admire everything about
that
what the public perception is because i
don't live in a house but the public
perception of the situation is a good
situation we've seen fathers and sons in
boxing and sometimes it don't go too
good like roy jones jr and his pops you
know
killing his dog ain't the greatest
thought as a pops you know like
military training a young boy ain't the
brightest of ideas
um
but
that's
for devin haney to
beat ryan garcia he has to
put a perfect fight together
and
a perfect fight
a perfect fight
oh oh okay so listen listen they already
started
the the co-main event
and you have zahas versus uh espasada
and
and
zaya's just uh dropped espacada
in the first round so this might be we
might get that t.o
like that baby this combat talk might be
short tonight baby because i don't think
teo's going to go
long in that fight hopefully not
hopefully he doesn't go 12 rounds or
whatever and talk about i needed the
rounds crap
um
but right now uh there's they're
circling
after the knockdown and you have um
a spotters uh against the corner and uh
zaha's is
is uh you know hunting him right now
jabbing
uh they're breaking them up in the
middle of the ring right now but we will
save the play-by-play for the actual
main event
um
but again
you know uh
ryan garcia going in that fight with
devin haney is a 50 50 fight yo i'm
gonna be i'm be honest with you the only
fight that i would not say is a 50 50
fight with ryan garcia is tank
that's like a 80 20 fight to me with
tank being the 80 and 20 being garcia
i give that boy a punches chance with
tank
because i know tank can take a shot
i see him take uh uh um
cruz's shots you know i seen him take a
lot of shots like
off of
excuse me
very strong dudes very capable boxes and
i've seen him stop and track
capable boxes so
tank would for me is the more
battle-ready
battle-tested
killer out of that group
he's the one if he i don't care who you
pick out of that group tio
shakur
you're always going to pick tank ahead
of all of them
even if it's even if it's by like temple
all right let's say it's like by devin
haney versus tank i say that 60 40 tank
right let's say shaquille stevenson
versus tank i say that is uh
55 45 uh tank right
tio fino lopez i say that's 80 20 uh
because uh tio exhibited that level of
chin that i don't trust you know uh
then you have uh let's say george
cambosis let's put him in the mix uh
against uh tank
i i give him uh a zero percent chance i
got tanked all the way in that fight
so
excuse me
anytime you you i i believe that's how
they view tank
they be they they they they view tank
as an obstacle if they go around we can
just go around them but if we have to
fight them then we will fight them
we will fight them so
yeah yeah yeah
good good ellis you watching the fight
too that's what's up
i mean this this fight started off
pretty decent the the the co-main it
started off pretty decent they they both
have good boxing skills and espada is is
definitely uh giving some fight back
after being dropped and you want to see
that you don't want to see somebody you
know just take the lay down stay down um
he's he's putting his punches together
he's fighting back
but um at the same at the same token zaz
is um
calm and composed
calm and composed
and he's and he's taking his stalking
into
um good territory what you want to do
when you drop somebody and and and
especially to the head
you want to keep using your jab to keep
ringing that belt don't let him clear
his cobwebs just
keep touching them
every so often hit the body
but keep touching them
keep touching them and
just keep that jab in his face so that
he doesn't see the overhand right
excuse
me
or if you're southpaw
he doesn't see that overhand left come
across
and
then you drop him see right there he
caught him with that left hook
and i'ma tell you man this this is a
good co-main event
uh two
unknown fighters at the moment
especially for me
and and i watch a lot of boxing but this
is the top ranked fact the top rank has
all these guys that they put on
short contracts and stuff like that and
they go all over and they just pull them
in to fill a card
where you want a card filled with names
but how do you get names
this is how you get names you get names
like this so you put them on a good card
with teo fema and um hopefully these
dudes build into the next cold because i
remember seeing miguel cotto on
i believe it was probably a margarito
undercard or something like that
so
and and i and i got a chance to watch
him grow so let me see
oh who's the most beautiful mary j
or alicia key
who's more beautiful
mary jay or alicia keys
all right you
uh now i got to go to alicia keys
alicia keys is
have you ever seen that person
alicia keys is ridiculous
lemon
alicia keys
oh zayas is getting a little tagged up
man oh my god that double left hook and
that right hand zaias is is is tight
with his punches zayas is showing me a
little something special
i mean i'm not gonna lie i didn't expect
that from zionists but zayas is showing
me something special
that oh wow zayas
off off a catching pitch like he caught
the shot and he pitched right off of it
and and he and he hit uh xbox
with that shot that's kind of crazy
very good very good stuff
but
now that we getting close to that fight
that we want to see
that bud
versus spence
i'm seeing all these dudes starting to
switch details
mike tyson
oh yeah uh spence is a monster now and
you know um you know he shows gr you
know crawford can't stay still you know
before was yeah crawford to kill him you
know
[Music]
then you had uh james tony mumblemouth
[Music]
you must have forgot
you must have forgot that a dude that
could break you down and tear you up
would do exactly that and
i don't know man
not everybody
well you know
spence i i know
they realized before they probably
thought it was not gonna happen right
so you can talk all the crap in the
world where you don't think something's
gonna happen right ah kick your butt
after school
and when he's like all right let's fight
you
what
huh
[Music]
yeah
i cannot wait for that fight to happen i
cannot wait for that fight to happen i
cannot wait i'll probably go on an hour
ahead of time because that's going to be
one hell of a card
i can't
wait for that fight to happen
and i've been telling people
like tank said
blood's good
buds good but but gonna get his ass
knocked out
oh my god yo let me tell you something
zazz is
no
joke
zaz is no joke his left hook
is definitely crazy
but i'ma tell you
this dude espos
esparada is
he's he's weather in the storm
like
he's taking the shots and he's still
there i don't this dude has one hell of
a chin
one hell of a belief and he's still
coherent like he's still slipping shots
with the shots that he's getting hit
with
you're not supposed to be able to slip
shots after that only shots you supposed
to be able to slip is you slipping right
under them ropes
but espos maybe he might punch himself
out
you know i mean uh zos
maybe might he might punch himself out
oh my god yo i'ma tell you right now if
this dude come back and win this
that that's that's one for the books
that's one for the books you write that
one up right there
oh man that left [ __ ] is serious man he
just don't take the left hook well
he just do not take the left hook well
the spiders does do not take the left
hook well man that love hook is crazy
zasala [ __ ] is nuts i like his left hook
i'm a left hook dude
they both work horses and dogs in the
ring facts can't wait to see i want
spins to win but crawford's a problem
breakdown crawford doesn't break down
his opponents man just look at it
look at the fights
a lot of his a lot of let's let's let's
call a space play right
a lot of crawford fights was them top
ranked dummy up fights
that's why his record is 36 and
something something crappy crappy
but name them
exactly
that part
so
and and a lot of people won't be like
but can you you know you he could only
fight who they put in front of him yeah
yeah yeah top-ranked stuff i'm not
taking away from bud scale i'm not
saying but it's not skillful but it's
skillful
i told you i reserve
on on that port of fight i reserve
judgment on the portal fight being that
they're friends
and let me give you let me give it to
you this way
if me and lemon's in a fight game
and
i don't establish myself i'd have been a
champion i didn't did this and that in a
third
excuse me
lemon is coming up in weight
he's coming up from cruiserweight
i know i'm about to leave i'm my heart
is not in the game or whatever and
lemon
is getting out of his contract with his
promoter
and he's looking for a big name i'm a
big name
i'm going to leave me and lemon cool
i'm going to make money with my boy
but like yo we go we'll fight hard but
really it's my dude
i'm a job for them
kind of weird right
wwe
i'm just saying
if if it was really real
and you really beat me
and they stopped the fight in that
manner my pop stopped the fight
there's no way in hell i'm going on your
podcast tomorrow
and that's exactly what happened
so
eyeballs just eyeballs just it's just
eyeballs in a situation so
um but at the same time
at the same time i'm not discrediting
what i see from but
but skill is great
but then you got to look at the resume
of spence
spence skill is great
but it's resumed oh
at that 147
that that 147 he god tear
he didn't talk through everybody that
was there that was it was this except
for keith thurman who who docked him you
better not duck me thing
him
you better not duck me son you see me
coming son you better not dock me son
well he docked him so
i'mma tell you man
yeah retirement check
you know that mayweather carried him
carry cotto the whole fight
the whole
fight
12 rounds
carried him
no man
always look at these little love heart
sweetheart packages
look at these packages man
and and i honestly believe that's how
the package went so regardless to what i
know bud wants to get the most money for
this fight um and he and he's gonna get
the most money that he can possibly get
for this fight if it's not backhand back
end money or or upfront money it's it's
definitely good yo i'm gonna tell you if
anybody's watching
this uh co-main event
you're getting your money worth
i i don't think esparas is taking the
left hook well from uh zaha's
but
i do say this
i do say this this this is
definitely
a good
undercard fight now is it a cold main
event fight no
but it's a good up and coming fight
so because you got espos
and zaha's zazz is death is dancing now
he's he's on his toes he has his hands
down
he's doing that you know when you're
feeling yourself move when you ah
throwing that hook throwing that jab
he's dead
smitty smith what's going on baby smile
dude sweetie smith yo
smitty has been around with us
for forever man like forever smitty
smitty man shout out to you and the
family smith yo uh you've always
just been
a dude that's been there man do you do
you know how incredible that is to have
people that have rocked with you for
for a minute and a lot of you have like
but i mean come on man
y'all indulge in my stupidness you know
talking about fights and stuff man
like
that's craziness like we up at night
like
10 o'clock yo we popping like who think
the lord is going to be up at 10 o'clock
at night me
me with my one drink
so
it's just like i don't know man y'all
y'all gonna love kos because you ain't
gonna have to see
this room y'all gonna y'all gonna get
the chance to see them
the
purple room
and get a chance to see that
you're gonna be like oh that's that's
kind of crazy
you're gonna get a chance to see that um
you get a chance to see a whole bunch i
know y'all tired of seeing these statues
shout out to acg
i got to send him a picture
of my uh kingpin
oh he dropped him
this fight is over
yeah
zaya's definitely put it in put his
stamp on this right there
um he dropped them
uh i'll give you a recap on what punch
he actually knocked him out with
he said
you know they even posted sorry for the
strong language used at this program
yeah that that was a good one yeah all
right a good one right ooh
definitely
definitely this this
all
all the fights tonight has been
mid
this
was for that bread i mean somebody these
dudes here
they they took it they took it right
shout out puerto rico
all puerto ricans stand up man
you got a little something here
excuse me you got a little something
here you got a little something here he
has something
he has a little spark he can just
tighten up a little bit of things
but he has a little spark he has
something and i'm gonna tell you man
that's
that dude can take us a shot he's like a
timex watch
take a licking and keep on ticking
remember that lemon
you could take a licking and keep on
picking the timex watch it's definitely
incredible
i used to beat it up they used to throw
it off the mountains
you said these all it's still working
i don't know have i ever had a time max
out though
i don't know
oh my god yeah it was an overhand right
yo
that left hook caught him bit on the
shoulder
boom
dear god
whoa
overhand right boy he had to he had to
fall back
oh
good god oh he hit him with the
spotty shaker
oh good god
his body was just like let me have a
seat over here he did the genuine yes
oh the box oh do the genuine
oh my god
ain't nothing like it boy ain't none
like boxing he he ain't got nobody
looking around dude but his self
he look at himself like yeah i got
caught with that man you know you don't
want to look at the replay
it ain't like football you look at a
replay of a dude burning you in the
field and you can't he
getting the touchdown eye
you didn't know that you got knocked out
like
you see the video you're like oh damn
that was me
yeah the ref could have let them fight
though and die
what you trying to do what what you oh i
see you want you got a broken bone you
want broken bones you handed it out i
see i see what you get
that referee said oh hell no what the
referee hearing the shots the referee
seeing the boy body turned into jello
what you trying to do
no no no that that guy he needs to get
up tomorrow stop it stop the lemon he
needs to go and take care of his kids he
needs to count his money
his paycheck he gotta cash it
bank close on sunday buddy you know he
deposited and then on monday
oh man
puerto rico you got something baby
you got son this kid he you you know who
you know who's happier than anything
right now bob aaron
bob aaron said
[Laughter]
i got him on contract for the next 45
years
barbarum is is is is a real life vampire
not saying that he's sucking the blood
out of everybody which probably is but
he a real life vampire that man don't
die
i remember when it was just him and don
king
i haven't seen don king in a minute even
though don king is still
doing his thing you know with his son
and stuff shout out to carl king you
know a hell of a dude nice guy you know
um
but don king
he used to be
right there
where is he
exactly but you still
see your boy bob aaron bob aaron still
got top rank bob aaron kept top ranked
rolling remember don king had show time
bob aaron had hbo
show time still going strong
hbo dead
bob arum's still alive baby
i'm still alive
and he still has the capabilities of
getting people like devin haney
shaco stevenson tio filmo lopez uh
lomachenko
i'm still alive baby i still got game he
the illest pimp in the game bob
you said respect me baby respect me baby
i get all my girls here baby respect me
baby shout out to bob
bob
is
old school promoter
the best to do what he does
bob had floyd bob had cotto bob had
oscar bob had um
tyson fury
bob had bob
had
every great fighter
that you know
bob had has his hands they have went
through top rank in some form of fashion
bob is off the chains
shout out to barbara i'm still doing
what you do at the ag i think he like 90
years old 80 something he got to be like
88 90.
bob arum
is
a bad man a bad man not bad isn't evil
i'm talking about a bad isn't whip your
ass back like show enough
bad like kiss my converse bad that's
barbaro
let me see let me see hey
danny's pops did genuine after that
[Music]
yo don't put that all at me
don't put that on that man like that
don't put that on that man
jump on it
let's do it
you wild crazy
but we have the main event getting ready
to come up right now man
and i'm gonna tell you man this this
this fight they're giving the kids time
to warm up they wanted to fight to go at
least
uh ten rounds
eight to ten rounds so they could just
bring them straight out and bring them
in remember they have uh they have spots
like uh
promotional spots and stuff like that
that they have to go through so
at the same time
they have to let it happen they have to
let it go through so again you know
hopefully
hopefully this would be a little bit
faster
um but tio
this could be tio's uh first round uh ko
that could
i don't know how
this is one of the weird ones right it
it was even just like um
the benavidez uh
uh
garcia fight danny garcia
um
you know
i didn't know
what garcia we was gonna see
did i
think that was gonna see that garcia
that we did see hell no
hell no i did not think that we was
gonna see that garcia
that garcia i haven't seen that garcia
and maybe because i've never had to see
that garcia when i talk to people they
tell me stuff like oh that's how he was
in um
when he was in the amateurs
you know danny fought on his toes he was
a active counter punch and stuff like
that i'm like oh okay
uh but the danny that i s i see
is uh
is a is a boxing slugger counter puncher
flat-footed
uh
not on his toes
when he fought benavidez
he was on his toes
he was moving in and out he was given
angles
danny was showing defense like
and he was still counter punching so
i i i don't know man i didn't expect to
see that that danny and that damn sure
expected benavidez to cut off the ring
more and to do more and not just posture
and
and do animations with his face i
thought he was gonna
mix it i thought i thought it was i
wanted to see what happens when the
pressure is on danny what i don't want
to see is a danny garcia versus keith
thurman
that's not what i want to say i do not
want to see that you know um i want to
see those two fight different people i
don't want to see the two old dudes
fight each other to hell with that
i want y'all y'all did that already we
saw that we saw that 12 rounds of that
we saw that y'all don't have no belts
there's nothing to prove
now so don't don't give me that give me
danny versus boots or or boots versus
thurman
danny versus
uh charlo uh jamelle
not jamal jamal had a back injury he had
to pull out his fight with this guy uh i
don't even you know what
not saying that he didn't have a back
injury but a lot of times
if sales of tickets
ain't hitting what it's supposed to hit
uh you fall back
whatever because you know you're always
going to have injuries you you're always
gonna catch an injury nobody goes into a
fight a hundred percent you know there's
always something nagging something
something but you overcome these things
because the purse is so good and
everything is so good because i'm gonna
tell you right now
you can have a cold you can have you can
have whatever
if your balls telling you yo um if you
come in today i'm giving you a double
time double-time pay
you'll be in there with a head scarf
with a doobie on wrapped up
shivering yeah i'm cool answering phones
yeah hello yeah well like to sell you a
carpet
so don't don't don't so these dudes get
paid
hell of a money
so you know if ticket sales are slowed
up and
you know promoters like yo is everything
all right
no
my back hurt or my foot
they give you time to step back off that
so
man they're showing
champions
champions i'm i mean i i watch
all these champions i've watched with
pino cuevas i watch
julio chavez
i watch
all of these
dudes man
oh my god
i've watched i was a huge fan of tommy
hearns
you know haggler versus hearns i'm a
huge fan of haggler
huge boxing fan like
you know and i believe we can get those
times
we can get those days back
you know those those slugfest is you
know these dudes was fighting for
less pay
but it was more dynamic and the money
messed up boxing to be honest with you
the money messed up boxing because
now
we're at a point where
dudes is trying to get the most money
for the least resistance you
know
after this week iap is going to be so
fun
you had a bad week cooper
but i got you
wow man
you're seeing
some of the greatest fights
they're showing some of the greatest
fights i guess this is top ranks history
in in in excellence and wasn't we
talking about that how bob arum
oh ali was a monster ali was a monster
he's dropping koopa
he's dropping koopa
um
i i can't lie you know
top rank
man
hopefully
we we can get promoters like this i mean
we got al haymon
al haymon
was trying to clean the sport up
so
then
you have eddie hearn i have no faith in
eddie hearn because i can't believe
anything eddie hearn says so we have a
service for you and there's no
pay-per-view because pay-per-view is the
way of the dinosaur but
now he's having pay-per-views
so
what was true what what was said before
what you're doing now
i paid money for the service
now you're asking me to pay more money
sound like some ratting dudes that i
know
so i i don't know man
yeah don't y'all listen when don king
got that bag from showtime and mike
tyson was his ticket through
he had julio cesar chavez
and
dave steamrolled
steam rolled
through
think about it this way
the card was so serious
that julio cesar chavez was the co-main
event
you talking about somebody who was
85 or 81-0
cold main event
he didn't become the main until
tyson went to jail
don king put together cards that he was
like wow this car
tito trinidad
yo
he
put together fight cards
that will have
tito
behind julio cesar chavez
and the headline is mike tyson
we would right now
you would throw your money
at the television
to get a card like that
to get a card like that
and these dudes wasn't fighting bombs
you know everybody could sit there
saying mike tyson was fighting bun fight
mike tyson was fighting whoever was the
champ or whoever was the top five
competitor
at that time maybe you may not agree
with it
cool
julio shays or salvage you can say oh he
fought a lot of tijuana cab drivers yeah
early on
those fights wasn't broadcast
but he was fighting top 10 competitors
top five people in in ring
tito
fighting top five
top ten competitors
don king put together some cards
like i told you it was too it was one it
was it was a and b it was you know uh uh
uh heckle and jackal
bob aaron and don king
that's competitive genius those dudes
was fighting
for your dollar
we don't get that now let me see now i
call it jim ryan on the first 48 with a
blurred face you stupid
king off topic but what do you think
about wilder and his comeback don king
might be the go yeah he might be um
i wish wilder's success
i don't know
what wilder
does
right now
because i don't know the mind state of
deontay wilder
i don't know if deontay wilder
mind state is
you know um
he's coming back
because
this guy is gone
which which makes sense he's coming back
to finish his business with aj
he's coming back because
before tyson fury he was the most
dominant heavyweight
what did the tyson fury fights take away
from deontay
what did did it take away from him
physically what did it take away from
him mentally
all those questions will be answered
soon as he gets in the ring
so
that's another fight that's like a danny
fight
you know um
that's like a teo fight
what what what deonte wilder are we
going to get this is going to be the
year of the questions and the answers
you know we we had those questions with
uh spence like after the car accident
i don't care what nobody said going into
that fight with him
and danny garcia a heavy-handed puncher
that can crack you and get you out of
there anytime
what were we going to see and him and
danny exchanged some shots in that fight
was he going to be able to take it was
he going to walk through that fire
will he be willing
you know deontay wilder got knocked out
is he going to be willing
to go
and fight through that fire again is
that fi
what is missing out of that king is it
still there is it this is still burning
that's what we're trying to figure out
so
i want to know
yes sir
here we go
they are trying to drag this out right
now they're trying to get to the sponsor
what time let me see
yeah it's 1107.
they have campus coming out right now
he's happy
biggest check in the world he's happy
and yo
don't you do your job better when you
you gotta smile your pockets right
you do everything better when your
pockets right
let me see what he said let me see
oh walla put
a whole while to put in that gym work
and respect the game like me and you did
yeah yeah
hold on
yeah yeah you listen
first of all
jake paul
knew he wasn't gonna fight rockman
the way the contract was set up he was
setting him up to lose
he didn't expect rockmod to lose that
weight
he didn't expect that
no fight is cancelled for weight
none
you take money away
you do all types of things no fights is
canceled for weight
none
okay
none
tickets are sold venues is sold out
money is being made
you ten pounds over you five pounds over
i'm going to charge you fifty thousand a
pound
twenty thousand a pound ten thousand a
pound whatever the hell it is i'm going
to we're gonna come up to an agreement
right here but this fight gonna happen
that fight ain't happening because
somebody didn't want that fight to
happen and you know who didn't want that
fight to happen
the main event didn't want that fight to
happen
all right so
he was going to fight a real boxer
and
he would have been in some real trouble
is it a sucker move yeah is it a smart
move
he got you talking he got you interested
so
you never know
um
that's an entertainment that's not a
fight
that's entertainment
don't get it mixed up with what we see
in here with teo fimo coming in
um
don't don't don't
don't get it messed up with
actual boxing events
that's entertainment
that's for the fun of it
you're going there you have a good time
you drink your party hey hey wuty wu
have a good time
and that's it
jake paul is jake paul not saying that
he he's not trained trying to fight
he's not trying to fight
nobody i can whip his butt somebody
asked me who should jake paul fight said
mike tyson so mike tyson can slaughter
him and we can go back to living life
i would love for him to fight
a 50-something year old mike tyson
to put the hurt on him
put the hurt on him
jake is a serious boxer he's training
like a a real box i'm not saying he
doesn't
i see a bunch of dudes at the ymca
hitting the bags i see a bunch of dudes
trying to give the best i'm not saying
that he he's he's
not he is in a situation where he's used
his
influencer bag
to influence a bag
let me let me explain how
let's say iron lord's podcast had a
million followers
and then i parlayed this
into calling out
uh
another
podcaster
i call out another podcaster
and i fight him
ksi
all right luke paul
i parlayed that into a bag
then i parlayed that into another bag
and then i parlayed that into another
bag
am i more credible because i used to box
or am i less credible
because i podcast
right
you have to ask yourself
it was entertainment
that that fight with ksi
entertainment
jake paul
saw his brother
i'm gonna give me a bag too
are you crazy
they're giving her money like that
snatch floyd hat got your hat
look at me
please
give me your bag
are you nuts
that's how it goes
cloud chasing at its finest
make y'all think make believe is real
and they did a great job
listen to this
you said mike tyson in his prime
will eat him alive
mike tyson today
would hit that boy
and make him release himself in the ring
literally you ever seen a brown round go
down
see y'all haven't been through the
amateurs to see people get hit with a
body shot and
all over itself
you said me versus god that they would
they couldn't put enough money in into
that fight for that to happen
but
remember
i was an amateur boxer
remember
i'm six foot four
285 pounds
cog
is not
stop
all right
stop that's
does any make any sense
yeah the brown round going down this is
def
listen
we we used to bet on who can give
somebody the brown round
we used to bet like yo then you'll catch
him you can catch him
all nighty baby all nighty
uh-uh
make somebody boo boo
boo boo on himself
he's smelling like
let me know
let me know the brown round
listen
lemon
no
lemon nose man
that's why he put the laughing all right
so they get ready fight let's go
they already they already talked them in
they're already into the fight let's go
all right well he's he's the takeover
that's too female lopez
let's get it
all right so tl comes out double jab to
the top and to the bottom
all right uh
pedro is guarding with an open guard he
open guard is this his elbows is open
giving uh teo an um an inviting uh
target
tio throws an overhand right
camper duck's low
t.o goes to the midsection right now
they're just circling each other
in the middle of the ring
posturing
and tio looks like he's hydrated he's
probably
at least
143 144 right now
uh campus looks like he's at least 147
right now
so you know um we we do uh t.o throws
the overhand right
uh and campos uh accepts it nothing too
much right now it's uh t.o hits him with
an uppercut as he slid over to his left
um after he threw a overhand right so
theo's trying to land the overhand right
he's getting a little bit overzealous
his punches is a little bit wild uh
campos is really not throwing too much
tia's back on the stick he's moving back
throwing the jab
campus goes uh up and down uh to the jab
top and bottom and he throws overhand
right and
catches t.o.t.o backside of that and
turns they're back in the center of the
ring
t.o is tabbing him to the stomach and
going back to the face
and uh he's trying to throw up jab all
right so campus throws a one two three
and catches t.o frozen with his um
right hand to the side of his head
all right so and tio initiates the grab
right now
let me see
all right they're back in the center of
the ring
all right so uh
they're just in a clinch right now
nothing too much got 53 seconds in a
round
tio's back to the jab right hand
he he shot the overhand right and he
tried to freeze uh campbell
camper is very calm very relaxed
uh he's stalking t.o.t.o's uh backing up
the person leading right now is camper
all right so
hey
theo is moving his back is close to the
ropes
camper is uh stalking him again
right hand to the body to initiate and
grab
pushing forward
and
13 seconds left in the round
all right uh
tampa
is attacking t.o
is fighting off the ropes and
lopez catches them with a left hook at
the end of the round
all right so
what i see is what uh
theo just wanted to get out of the first
round
he threw a couple of good shots if the
shots presented itself he was going to
take it
was it too much no
uh campo was baiting him when he was
doing open guard he was begging him so
he had his gloves like this
chin
right here cheek level and he has open
guards elbow flit so that means that's
inviting for you to come down the center
to go to his gut when you go to his gut
he'll shoot her overhand right or shoot
a jab coming in making you stop and then
he'll shoot her right and then he'll
step in and work the body or whatever
but this open guard it gives you the
illusion setting a trap
all right so
he's he's a pretty capable fighter
i saw some stuff
t.o right now
is sitting down
there up
second round i give this up until like
five rounds
to be honest with you
all right so we got uh lopez back in the
center of the ring there on a bud light
sign and uh shout out to blood light
give me a sponsor uh and uh tio is still
jabbing to the body
uh again campus is doing the actual
stalking
which is strange theo is he did a
leaping left hook
and he's trying to dig campers to the
body into the side of the head
remember this is teal's first uh
time in his weight class all right so
his first bout in his weight class and
that could play a difference
well campus is still doing the stalking
teo is on the back foot
all right
and the leading of the fight is done
right now by kampa
kampa and and tio is bouncing back
and he's giving uh
angles
but um
you have campus
still stalking still throwing the left
and the right
all right so um teo's on the ropes and
he catches campus with four or five
shots bouncing off the rope of campus is
still again
being offensive-minded and tio is trying
to set a trap to hit compass he hits him
with the overhand right and another
overhand right campus hits him with
overhand right and tio initiates the
grab referee breaks them up they're back
at again
and
back to the corner
and campus is again stalking teo
while tio is counter punching so he has
a jab teal steps to the side
and campbell throws him one two three
catches teal to the face t.o grabs
all right
t.o throws the overhand right i mean um
campus throws overhand right get a steel
campus throat jabbing his way in
and uh tio throws the uppercut and the
left hook campus slides out the way and
throws a one two and he has teo up
against the rope i'm gonna tell you
right now campus is being the more
aggressive fighter in all of this
all right so left hook from campus
campus throws a jab
all right and campus is throwing more
jabs
uh and getting t.o to slide to his left
so right hand from tio off the ropes and
he's giving angles but campus is still
stalking and he's always every time tio
is up against rope he's a one two
all right so
one two
all right teo initiates the grab again
kappas goes right back to center the
ring stalking jab
jab up
we have 10 seconds left in the round
campus is uh has t up against the ropes
and campus is countering effectively teo
is throwing a right hand and holds
i give that round
to camper
camper is initiating
all
the contact
and t.o is initiating all the clinches
hmm
something to think about
i i didn't think that um
[Music]
it would go in this way but there's a
possibility
mentally
did he accept his loss
because if you accept your loss you can
learn from your loss and what you learn
from your loss you can
fix yourself and do better
if you don't
yeah t.o is lighting them up
he said what did i think of garcia
during his ring post interview
i i didn't like that interview don't
give nobody a peek inside the mindset of
a fighter they can use it against you at
any time
stop looking for sympathy
you won
spencer was the better man at night
spins came from a car accident i don't
want to hear anything like that just let
it go
all right
so now they're back in the center of the
ring round three
and we have uh
they're jabbing right now but again the
lead guy right now
is campus right
and
tio
is
backing up
but he's countering
he catches campus with an overhand right
off of a counter and he's trying to
catch campus with an under
uppercut with overhand right
good setup but kampa seems unfazed and
he throws the one two again and catches
teal against the head tio catches him
with the uppercut
and campus catches t.o with a straight
left
they're back in the center of the ring
tio is using more jabs now
but campus is still taking the lead
oh beautiful left hook off the spin
from uh teo tio catches them with
another left hook is a hybrid hook
uppercut
and he's giving him angles and his right
hand t.o catches them with a right hand
campus catches teo with a right hand
beautiful footwork from theo
but campus throws a three-punch
combination that all lands on teo in the
center of the ring right now they're
fighting on the bloodlight sign
and
they backed up t.o right now is digging
into a camper's body
t.o is backing up
giving angles
against the rope and campus is still
scoring
while tio is posturing
uh t.o gave him a shoulder bump and a
short uh chopping right
campus uh punches t.o grabs initiates
clinch they're broken up
campus is still
all of this
one two three can uh
tell female back is up against the ropes
campus through those three shots one two
three
jab right hand jab
uh campus catches teo backing out of the
clinch with a straight right hand
tl's back up against the ropes
all right
camper is again
shooting the shots
tio clinches right after he lands a
chopping right hand
jab to the belly from camper
left hook from tio
got 26 seconds in a round
right hand from teal
left hook right hand from teal
jab
straight jab from teal
but campus comes back again and he's
still landing
campus is leading 10 seconds left in the
round
campus
is throwing left right left
and tio is playing around
all right and
round is over
um that one was a weird one to score
because teo had huge spots in that round
but campus was again still pushing the
fight
huh
if i if if you want if i had to pick who
i wanted to be in that round i would
have to pick teo
teo was doing a lot of good
defensive uh moves a lot of footwork
uh
good body work with a left to the body
and right over the top
so
but compass was still pushing and
dictating pace
so
dictating pace
has to stand for something
but again
tio
tio had had to get that round so i so
far two rounds to one
so we're at the fourth round
all right so
here we go campus goes right back to the
one two jab
right
all right so they're back in the center
the bud light sign
teo is still backing up but he's jabbing
to campus body and he throws a left hook
and an overhand right
campus doubles in
goes right back to teo's body catches
teal up against the ropes
t.o catches him with overhand right
and campus is right back to the jab to
the body
and i just noticed something
campus caught uh teal with a left hook
he has t.o
flinching off the shots
all right so compost is hunting
and
throwing a right hand tio tried a short
in left hook
uppercut
or a right hand uppercut and it missed
all right good
good clinch
uh from tio the back of the center the
ring
campos is a jabbing and he's still
stalking to you
jabbing him to the body any time he gets
it in close he jabs him keeps them in
range
and teo has to do a lot of working
to evade shots
all right campos is throwing a one two
every time he gets in distance there's a
one two
all right
compost is coming in jab one two's right
hand tio is not eating these shots well
right one two three from campos to a jab
t.o smiles
and acknowledges what campos did and
catches campos with an overhand right
compost is
one two three
and thio initiates the grab
referee breaks him up
tio is uh doing a george foreman type of
defense
right now
and he misses campbell's taps his chin
like come on
and he jabs teo in the face and he goes
right back to jab and tio and he shoots
the right hand t.o back is up against
the rope campos catches the uppercut
close
and
tio lands an overhand right
nice jab from tio
compost goes right back to the jab
33 seconds in the round
compost is stalking teo's holding
compost is back on them
jab
and jab right hand left hook
jab to grabs
and they they fight out the clinch
lopez
throws a one two three
one two three four
very flashy he's trying to win the round
at the end
ten seconds
all right
t.o is trying to fool the judges into
the fact that he didn't lose that last
round i believe that he lost the last
round because if i'm choosing who i
wanted to be i wanted to be compa camper
kept the pressure on he evaded a lot of
shots and closed he slipped to the left
he slipped to the right he caught a lot
of the uppercuts on the side of the
glove
and he counted
every time he got in distance he threw a
one two to keep the pace
after he kept pace
excuse me
teo will counter off the ropes with
uppercuts and left hooks uh and right
hands but it wasn't enough to sustain a
round for me it was in spots and i think
compass was more sustainable in the
round to be honest with you i give them
both their two rounds even to me
both
oh four guys recorders what's going on
to my boy clowns
my my my my
mob connect
what up clowns
all right so
now we got him they back in the center
of the ring
t.o looks a little bit flat-footed some
when he comes out he's walking left and
right he's given angles
all right and i think he needs to get
out his head and stop trying to use
every trick that he learned
uh in the gym from his loss and actually
fight freely
because
campos is still not he he's have
supposed to have put in more hurt on
campbell's so far
campos is walking him down t.o is trying
to fight
but he initiates the clinch again
excuse me
all right so campus throws overhand
right and throws the left hook tl spins
off the ropes back into the center of
the ring but campos is stalking him
again
goes right back to a jab
and theo tries to shoot overhand right
campos is still there
campos high guard remember i told you
open
shoot right hand from campos jab from
campos campos is stalking right hand
left hook anytime he gets close remember
i told you he shoots a one two every
time he gets close
so we can tell the game plan
all right
t.o hit him with a body shot and game
off the ropes and landed a right hand
all right one two three from campos
overhand right from campos short right
from campos all right teo comes under
and throws under campos throws a one two
three
t-o holes
all right
so campos throws the right hand
and tio is dancing left and right campos
throws another right hand taps him to
the body t.o initiates clinch
campos is right back on them
when they break campos is right back on
him like a harbor shark stays on him
teo's there but campos is leading
t.o is countering
so we already seen the the
posture of the fight so far you have the
lead and you have the counter
the count is teal the lead is compa
compa throws the overhand right to your
counters with a left to the body and a
left to the face with overhand right
while he's backing up so it's not too
much leverage on his shots uh campus is
catching him one two three tio catches
him with a punch off the ropes but
campus is still on them
campus doubles up with the jab walks
teal down
kills tio's posturing
and he comes in with a shoulder
campus pushes him off and he goes back
into high guard and catches teal with a
left hook and catch him zoom with a jab
at the end of the round we have 10
seconds left
overhand right from tio
and tio misses wildly at the end of the
round
again i will have to get that round
accomplished because i believe campus
gave more than what he was taking all
right so we already see the mentality of
the fight is the master slave mentality
the master's the one that's going to be
leading the slave is going to be the one
that's countering so
uh if these references mess with you
this is what we talk about in boston
this is what you're supposed to be right
you want to be the leader you don't want
to be the trail you don't want to be
the caboose you want to be the actually
the engine of this train and right now
the engine of this train is compa all
right um
so tio is rolling a lot of these shots
but he's getting caught in between these
shots he's giving but his power isn't
translating
like it was in the lighter weight class
the heavier weight the stronger the guys
yeah frank bruno y'all know that shades
of frank bruno he was on me like a
harbor shock
all right here we go they're back in the
center of the ring
we got round six
all right so
campus just hit teo under the ribs with
a nice right hand
and he's walking him down
all right so
one two three
compass
is jabbing
jabbing
all right
oh left hook
from tio
one two three from compass
all right
compass is back to jab and tio is trying
to lead
is this going to be the round he takes
the lead overhand right from t.o
all right back to leading again is
campus
camper is throwing the jab to the body
to freeze teal against the ropes and
he's varied it went and hit t.o to jab
to the head and through a right hand
all right and he's throwing the right
hand teo is switching
all right
campus is still
following t.o
t.o is jabbing
keeping a campus off balance
all right
one two from teo to the body
and he's backing up and campus
catches co with a one two and he's
slowing down so this is the marketable
difference that i see so far
in this fight as campus is slowing down
he's still doing the leading but right
now he's giving more distance to lopez
so lopez is able to counter cleanly
now without the pressure on top of him
he's able to land shots
from a distance and he needs that
separation in order to land his shot so
he's going to a jab
campus is stalking throws a right hand
left hook
t.o rolls out and hits him with a right
hand campus is throwing a one two theo
is uh weaving and catches him with an
uppercut and steps over to his left tio
is darting left and right
the mouthpiece came out for tia fiomo
lopez the referee picks it up
and they're back at the center of the
ring all right so
compa is back on to you
and he throws a left hook right hand
and t.o rolls out the way and he tries
to catch him with an overhand right but
misses wildly
all right so campus throws the one two
right and again
he's throwing the one two three
but tio is moving and he's pot shotting
him all right nice short left hook from
tio
leaping left hook
all right left hook right hand
from lopez
again
all right
all right round is over
if i had to pick who i wanted to be in
that round it's definitely teo so it's
uh that's a 3-3
so far
the problem is i saw
a marketable steep decline from camper
no longer was it the speed and tracking
no longer was he cutting off the ring he
started following instead of cutting off
the ring how you cut off the ring you
jab to the body you jab to the head you
step over you shoot the right hand you
track in distance when you're tracking
distance you bring the left to the body
you bring it across the middle and then
you shoot the right hand over the top
uh he
stopped
uh
tracking
and cutting off the ring and he was more
in a trail when he's trailing
it's not too good because you give teal
female the ability to pot shot you move
set up his traps because he's countering
he already submitted to the point that
he's going to be the counter in this
fight
all right
so round seven just started
and we got
all right
here we go
here we go stepping over teo is moving
from left to right
you have compass is on him
teal short left hook and down goes compa
from a left hook
from teo fema lopez
campa gets up i told you he stopped
cutting the ring off and started
following
tio comes out and he's going at him
all right
so here we go left hook from tio
body shot tried to end it with a right
hand
right back to the jab
right hand right hand from tio body
shots from tio
campus is not looking too good
all right teal switches to southpaw
and he's
uh
looking very awkward from southpaw
something that he doesn't need to do he
goes right back to orthodox
all right campus is coming back again
taking a lead role
because i don't think campus can
actually
box backing up so he's comfortable with
coming forward t.o knows this
and he says his traps are quarterly
all right so
nice jab from
lopez right hand
from teo teo steps move in
and does a lot of defensive moves
he's playing around
when he should be finishing off his
opponent all right he's playing nice
left hook nice right hand
all right
and then you have
campus is backing up throwing a one two
three valiant effort from campus we we
know t.o is definitely pot shouting
landing incredible shots one two three
campus is against a rope overhand right
tony weak stop the fight the fight is
over that's it
t.o
wins
um
and it was it was really good it was um
tio tino femo showing confidence
showing
that he's here i feel very good for the
young man
uh this is a good confidence builder it
was a lot of things that he could take
from this fight and learn from
like
if he's going to allow somebody to lead
which he is
then he can't get hit cleanly
all right at all
all right so
he got hit too cleanly with a lot of
shots but again still look like he can
go to club look like he can party uh he
needs to go right back to the gym he
can't get too high on this
all right but it was definitely a good
fight
accumulation of punches that's right
and in showboating
the showboating is for some people for
for some other people maybe not maybe
not a good thing but um
it shows that that's that's his stick
he wants to be a performer he wants to
be seen he wants to push numbers he
wants to do that
um
100
this this was a fantastic show
um i i i love
the fact that he showed some of the
stuff that he worked on in the gym i
think at a point he was trying to show
too much of the stuff that he worked on
in the gym uh but he definitely put it
all together when he got comfortable
i think and he he was leaping with a lot
of a lot of shots so he was off his feet
with a lot of his shots i think this
weight class isn't good for him
i think he needs to go back to 135
campaign there don't campaign at 140.
i think he needs to be at 135 but again
remember i told you i believe that he's
hunting ryan garcia
in that fight i got ryan garcia
if ryan garcia catches him with any of
these shots that compass caught him with
it's good night irene
all day
ryan garcia is faster ryan garcia is
stronger ryan garcia is sharper
ryan garcia is younger ryan garcia has a
little bit much more
but
tia fimo is more seasoned
one more fight at this weight before he
goes after garcia
in my opinion and he's a champion just
that that lets you know how high on the
hog i am for garcia
i
a lot of times i have my little things
with him i believe he wants to be more
of a celebrity than a boxer but again
we're living in a different age there's
a different time i'm an old fuddy duddy
that likes my stuff
only one way and the new way of doing
things is completely different you have
people talking about jake paul seriously
that's what i'm talking about so again
back in the days he would have never
been taken seriously in this day and age
people actually believe that he's a
competitive fighter so again
very good fight
something that was good to watch if you
actually got a chance to see it i watch
a lot of my stuff on sky network because
i like that that broadcast better i like
their stuff better so if he was in the
states and he was watching the stuff in
the states my stuff was a little bit
probably a tad bit behind um but again
thank you for hanging out with lord king
david the professional fan
combat talk with the king another
successful night thank you guys so much
for
just tuning in and watching um
i'm gonna give y'all that intro
all over again
and y'all have a blessed evening
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna send a contract out knock his
contacts out you a phil mice trying to
take a viper ain't no competition in the
ring decipher cause i'm spitting
financial swing of fire talking pickled
peppers make them pay the piper cause i
might go live like a rude discussion and
deflate your chest like a food reduction
you'll be talking like you want a new
concussion to do the custom attitude
adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i will serve haven't
sipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
captain you were phony homie now you owe
me action have them sinking tony tony
tony braxton and they all want to talk
for attention but the fame only lasts
for an instant mama got a hand so i'm
ready for the tension i'ma leave him
ready you can dance to redemption
[Music]
you